[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think one of the biggest challenges in
the valley and it's been going on for
over 20 years now it's been going on
since the mid 80s is the constant change
of the landscape itself within the bull
valley everybody's having to learn new
things every single year and that
includes animals can how they move
through the valley you know an example
of that would be many years ago
following a radio called a grizzly bear
into the bull Valley here and I remember
sitting at a at a corner waiting for her
to pop out and to try to keep her from
entering into a development and I
remember her popping out onto the edge
of the forest and going up her hind legs
and looking around and what used to be a
forest the previous fall was now
completely gone and was just a big
construction zone and I just looked at
her it was like she was thinking oh my
gosh what happened what do I do now
and I think it was a great example of
how wildlife are really struggling at
times to to figure out how to move
through the valley
[Music]
[Music]
well I know it's been described by some
bear biologists as being one of the
busiest landscapes the grizzly bears and
people continue to coexist and I'm not
aware of any community in North America
that's been able to achieve what we've
been able to achieve here so the whole
story of bears and garbage in the bull
valley started back in the 70s in the
national parks and in cameroon there was
open pit garbage dumps and bears
routinely wandered through town seeking
out garbage that people left that
curbside in 1980 I was warden in Banff
Park and we handled 75 bears that summer
that year they also had a mauling a
single large male grizzly bear mauled
four people one of whom eventually died
we fall to 747 because it was the
largest bear that we had a record in
Banff are going at night to feed on
garbage from the caboose restaurant
leftover steak bones and steaks and
chickens and chicken bones
they're probably been fattening on
people's food and garbage for a long
time before who were out fishing ran
into this bear at close range well of
his restaurant it attacked three of them
were serious injured one person died and
everybody pretty well agreed garbage and
grizzly bears or garbage and black bears
shouldn't mix
dangerous mist and then Parks Canada
it's a million or two million to clean
up the food garbage and they did them we
fast forward out to the early 90s
Kenmore had been discovered the town had
gone from four thousand residents to
almost 10,000 residents there was a
group of citizens here in Kenmore that
were really concerned that was trying to
force Town Council to do something about
bears and garbage and camel we were
learning very quickly that there was a
strong relationship between how we were
managing our waste and the impact it was
having on bears in habituating them and
attracting them in the town and
rewarding them once that connection was
clearly made then it was how do we
change what we thought was really
fascinating is it is recognizing that
bears can do this right but they can't
do that and so that's why the hinge is
facing down because that's something we
can do in the Bears have much difficulty
doing that it has not gone through any
changes in the last 20 years and so it
really shows that designed the interest
the collaboration really worked
you know us included figured that once
we got the garbage problem solved but
maybe that was going to be the end of it
and then we had bird feeders and you've
got a bird feeder bylaw put in and that
negate the bird feeder issue but eras
are always searching for food and when
one thing becomes unavailable they moved
to something else and then it's just
this constant trying to keep ahead of
the game and be aware of what's out
there and trying to manage for it
so right now we're going to deal with
this natural food attracted but it's
right on a busy is a trail there are
certain areas where we're just not going
to encourage wildlife to be in those
areas they're they're residential areas
and part of doing that means removing
the food source that is available within
the town footprint bears can travel
along the trail but we're going to
remove the food source because of the
high levels of human use and the type of
activity ie biking
problem is where we live bears filter
through here quite frequently but if we
leave an attractant out they then want
to stay and they get competitive and
then you have trouble so we're trying to
remove any reason for a bear to stay
just allow it to filter we only planted
the trees because we wanted flowers we
didn't really want the apples so we're
really happy the town is replacing the
tree with a flowering tree that won't
fruit Kenmore was a pretty sleepy little
resource town and then the Winter
Olympics happened here and suddenly
Kenmore became a kind of a destination
and development pressure started to grow
and that was the time when the whole
issue of wildlife corridors started to
get talked about and it is a fairly
simple concept I mean wildlife need to
move they need land to access food for
mates they need to interchange genetic
information between populations wildlife
tend to use very similar pathways and
those are what we kind of refer to as
corridors the best wildlife corridors in
in and around the town Academy are
already taken up by development
all these discussions were just starting
in can work around wildlife quarters and
connectivity
we're happening at a time when there are
also actually global discussions
happening within the field of biology
about the importance of connecting
isolated populations so individual
national parks and reserves with
regional level corridors and so if we
kind of zoom out from Canmore and look
at that it's you know Canmore is
actually important in that it's it's a
potential connection between BAFF
National Park and kananaskis country
it's also as you zoom out even more it
lights up as an really important
north-south connection and a much
broader reserve network that stretches
over 3,400 kilometers from Yellowstone
National Park all the way up to the
Yukon the trans-canada highway is a
major barrier to wildlife movement and
it cuts all along the bull Valley 20
years of effort have gone into highway
fencing and building wildlife crossing
structures that span this highway and we
know they work the wildlife collision
mortalities have decreased by 80% and
there's literally been over a hundred
thousand documented wildlife crossings
of these structures they are a key part
of the wildlife quarter network in the
bull Valley this is like the petri dish
of wildlife quality' science because we
still could string tight topography and
that's the really important point there
there's only a limited amount of land
here when you have you know species like
grizzly bears and cougars you know
cohabiting in areas where there's a lot
of human activity is a real real
challenge
[Music]
the town of Kenmore Council passed a
motion to get a stakeholder group
together to look at the issue of people
recreation in wildlife corridors and
habitat patches in a year and a half
we've collected more than one and a half
million photos or images and that
involves people and wildlife but what
we're seeing is that 94% of use in these
areas is human use about 61 percent of
them are rec reading with a dog and of
those people rec reading with a dog
about 60% of them have the dogs off
leash so what that tells us is that we
need to do a much better job at reducing
those pressures on wildlife most people
want to do the right thing just like
somebody in a city would check the
traffic conditions before they go out on
the road or skiers would check the
avalanche conditions before they go
skiing we will have resources available
to educate people in terms of where they
should and shouldn't be recreative based
on wildlife sensitivities so that people
can go in and look and see what trails
that they might want to avoid that day
today we are actually working on a small
piece of the overall project to
implement some restoration of the
habitat patch in South camera which is
where we are today
we're going to be restoring trails that
are unnecessary and reducing the linear
trail density throughout the area so the
area is more effective for wildlife in
doing that work in trying to address how
humans use the landscape in and around
Kenmore is really that we're giving
animals the space that they need to move
up and down the valley and get to the
places where they need to go we can
successfully coexist with wildlife
[Music]
the valley is becoming so busy that
there are people now who are choosing to
recreation that opens up the whole
forest to additional disturbance at a
time when wildlife aren't expecting to
see people around high human use
wildlife will often move under cover of
darkness so once you have people going
in with a lights at night at a time that
wildlife feels sick that they should be
secure then you're having a major impact
it's it's so great to be able to see
what species are using this landscape
and for me to be able to know that
Cougars and wolves and grizzly bears are
still using this area makes me very
optimistic but we are approaching a
critical point or we may even be at that
critical point and we need to start
taking these steps to conserve wildlife
movement through this valley for the
long term and we've still got a lot of
work to do we're not there yet
where's 148
throughout can't ask his country we call
red zones we have maps so people
understand what those are and we try and
make theirs understand what those are so
we just do not tolerate theirs within
within those red zones or no-go zones
and right now she's him she's you know
like a good spot other than there's a
lot of recreationalists around her
our reversal conditioning program works
with individual bears like like 148 here
em and we try and teach her individually
where she can and can't go and monitor
for her behavior it looks like she might
have moved a little bit back on front of
us there copy this is awesome for bears
but you know I've seen bears eat 20
salmon a day and to get the equivalent
berries it would probably do take them
weeks and weeks and weeks of very
feeding they are so focused they're they
know this is ephemeral this only lasts
for days or weeks so they're just head
down and they're eating as much as they
possibly can and every time
bikers are going by it's it's a bit of
an annoyance and I think that's what's
happening now we're seeing quite a few
cases of bears
huffing at people chasing people because
they don't want to be disturbed from
eating they don't they just want to
carry on doing what they're doing and
all when when they're surprised by
people it's that's not a good situation
for them the other thing we've been hit
by pokeyman going down to the park so
there's people walking around the trails
with their life with their smartphones
looking for Pokemon for Pikachu's not
looking for grizzly bears
it's exciting we can get her through the
next year or two into more mature adult
they tend to figure that a little better
but right now she's at teenager who's
one away from her mother or maybe she'll
cross the line make some mistakes and
that's why we're sitting here honor him
to make sure she doesn't really cross
any of those lines she's still moving
around a bit probably found a nice juicy
patch berries this is awesome cuz this
is that habitat enhancement blocked we
did for ungulates but you can see the
berries in here really nice over the way
spot and the best part is there's no
people oh yeah you guys have bear spray
yes should all because there's a grizzly
bear but 50 yards away from me right now
and should be making noise - is she
going yeah yeah so the smart people do
with the number of sightings and
everything else we're seeing here yeah
it just we're getting multiple sightings
absolutely crazy data conservation
officers are working overtime it's it's
a great berry crop and it's a great
great news for the Bears the
responsibility falls on people to behave
accordingly and responsibly okay so
we're doing a major media blitz campaign
going for social media we have people at
trailhead sense absolutely crazy there's
I think eight or nine warnings posted
seven or eight closures right now of
trails
it's absolutely overwhelming these few
weeks that are right in the middle of
our prime vacation time are super
formative for those bears and some
people are coming here from farther
afield and they came here for a specific
reason I'm gonna see a bear but we all
know that when humans and Wildlife come
too close together we could find
ourselves on a slippery slope that's
smart you know
let's avoid confrontation get a bear
spray it's worth 30 bucks and traveling
groups make some noise and if you kind
of feel uneasy turn around
go with your gut it's important for us
as people to step back and go home okay
what would life be like if we weren't
the center of the universe how can we
live differently
and at the end of the day is it really
that hard
here we have this wonderful opportunity
to living amongst wildlife and trying to
find this balance where we can do it
whatever it is we need to do to get
through our daily lives but we also have
the opportunity to to know that there is
these animals in the same Valley as us
where we live in recreation work
I suspect the elk are there one for the
green grass and tooth of the security
that that field is offering isn't it
sounds like we've been in contact with
each school in the valley here and have
developed wildlife protocols for the
school they are probably kind of
surprised and alarmed by the fact that
there's 60 elk in the schoolyard but I
bet you by the second or third day it's
all theirs the elk it becomes part of
their routine and I suspect the elk are
adapting as well and therein lies a bit
of the problem of this whole people
wildlife interaction thing everybody
just starts getting used to it but the
concern also is that we do have Cougars
and wolves in the valley and they prey
on elk you know they're potentially
really dangerous situations
[Music]
when I came back to Cameron I was in
charge of policing here and there was a
very tragic event with his Abell to be
but the end result was we had a death as
a result of an interaction with a
grizzly bear and a person and that kind
of crystallized people's thoughts into
how do we solve this but we had a lot of
really good people are good people with
fire in her belly interested in
conservation people with money for
development people with government for
power we have really the makings of a
very good group of people to solve a
problem and that's how wild smart
evolved who here has heard of wild smart
big kids included yeah just to get a
recap what are some of the animals that
live around here you can just call them
out that's okay with wild smart in 2016
I'll probably have completed 80 to 95
presentations the kids in this valley
that they're on it and they're so
interested in the local wildlife but
they also just have a wonder still and
they want to explore and they want to be
out which i think is really the
important part you know we have we
should stay wild we just want to be
smart about it that's really the main
goal I think the valley is unique in the
sense that we still have these animals
living amongst us or near us and a large
part of the global population is living
in urban areas they don't know wildlife
they don't know anything about them and
it's why we should try to maintain that
current
existence of wallet so that other people
can come and get a sense for what that
is all about because they're few and far
between these days we need to not rest
on our laurels and we need to stay
hungry and we need to try to stay ahead
of the curve because the challenges are
not going to go away but I just think of
my kids going down to the soccer pitch
and throw it on a can of bear spray
along with their helmet part of their
makeup is how they go about living and
they're creating in the valley and
that's a culture and that's that's the
future
[Music]
[Music]